thank you for joining us America Lynne
is in Washington DC Highland how are you
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call I'm really excited that I'm able to
talk with you today well you chose
what's awesome
I'm calling for some guidance I've been
listening to your radio program for a
year my husband and I are currently
taking SPU and when I was 18 years old I
opened some credit cards under my name
but I gave them to my parents I thought
I was helping them because they needed
some money at the time and they will
help me because they were building my
credit now I'm 31 years old and they
still have those credit cards open there
are eight credit cards still open and I
looked on my credit report today they
owe $13,000 almost $14,000 on those
cards and it's starting to cause some
strife in my marriage I have been
slightly upset about this we've been
working very hard towards the baby steps
and my parents have all this debt in my
name so can you help me so I'm a little
bit none of this is a good idea none of
it makes any sense
but if it had gone on for one year or
something it would make more sense than
having gone on this long what is wrong
with your parents they have I mean
big-time financial problems their whole
lives and you speak all the time on
changing your family tree and so my
husband are trying to do that but it's
hard when the roots know some parents
other roots and they're causing all
these problems at the very bottom of our
family tree so so Alan do all the cards
still have debt on them no the eight
that are open there are three that have
a zero balance closed them immediately
quite a lot about this okay until mom
and dad you're doing it
your parents live near you they do not
okay when will you see them again uh in
a few months they you visit often we
have a really good relationship but this
is like the white elephant in the room
you know very awkward husband has to say
nothing in the conversation but he needs
to sit there but he can't jump in
because he's way too pissed to talk
about this okay
and it will come out in his voice in his
body language but he sits there with you
and the four
you have a meeting and you start working
and you say mom and dad I am getting out
of debt myself and I'm closing all of
these accounts immediately and we need
to develop a plan whereby these loans
get paid off immediately
okay it's going on I made the monumental
mistake of one of the cards had a $5,000
balance and limits so it was maxed out
and it had like a 29 percent interest
rate so two years ago I told my parents
I'm going to pay this in cash so that
you can get out from under that interest
rate and it helps me because my credit
score was just tanked you know and if
you could make those payments to me and
then we all win and they have not lied
to pretty much maxed the card out again
they've matched the card out you didn't
close it I didn't I yes young and dumb
all right um well you have your parents
and you have serious boundary issues
between you I'm assuming you're done
with that and you're ready to set some
boundaries if you're not your husband
has tremendous reason to be pissed
I understand yes I'm ready for this I
mean my husband and I are now in baby
step four except we're really not
because in my name I had these credits
exact records open exactly so what I
would tell you to do is yeah I would
tell you to begin to have some phone
conversations with them and say mom and
dad when you are here next time we're
going to sit down develop a plan to pay
these off in the meantime I'm closing
these three and I would send letters to
each of the other cards certified mail
return receipt requested and get on the
phone saying these cards are to be
closed to further charges only the
existing charges the only reason the
account is left open is to pay down the
existing balance you can't close an
account with a balance but you need to
close it to further charges sure and and
that's going to be a fight because these
credit card companies are going to not
going to want to do that but they can do
it and they will do it and you lean on
them until they do it so that your
parents can't run up any more debt on
these things at least bring the credit
lines down to the balance okay or they
can't go over again right and but anyhow
close them to further charges and close
the the ones that
zero balances immediately okay
absolutely then get on the phone with
your parents and tell them what you're
doing and say next time you're here mom
dad I need to sit down with you we need
to develop a plan to pay this off and
hey we've been through financial peace
it's helped us we can put you guys
through it you know y'all need to talk
about this it's time for you to turn
your lives around but but either way if
you choose not to cheer and turn your
lives around I've got to get this
cleaned up for the sake of my family
and you can you can be gentle with them
and kind to them you don't need to call
them names and say you know Mom you've
always been a spender you've always got
this problem you don't need to bring up
any of that you just need to say here's
where we are today and here's where
we're going tomorrow okay today we're
thirteen thousand in debt with three
closed cards and five open cards
tomorrow and we're going to start
working at that snowball what's the
smallest balance I'm gonna care it is
537 dollars pay that one off today and
close it to me okay yes okay and be done
with it because what I'm doing here is
it's worth 500 bucks to limit your your
exposure right you're down to just four
cards then and you got to talk them into
shutting down further spending on them
not the parents the cards you follow me
on that and yeah and but your husband he
needs to be behind you cheering you on
and propping you up and reminding you
that you're not crazy and you're not a
bad daughter and all the things that
your parents may say and all that kind
of stuff but if he has to enter this
that he will never be forgiven by them I
understand once he starts then he's
they're going to blame him for being the
cause because they're the cause but they
don't think they're the cause they think
that life is unfair and all these other
BS right so um have you ever read the
book boundaries by dr. Henry cloud no
sir
I'm gonna send you a copy and I want you
to read it as soon as you get it all the
way through and get your highlighter and
your sticky pads ready you're gonna love
it thank you and it'll help you with
this conversation because these
conversations are very very hard for you
because you feel like you're doing
something wrong because you're not
taking care of family am i right mm-hmm
exactly yes and I want you to reframe
that in your mind it's not that your
mother's it
when you won't buy her medicine it's
that she does cocaine and you've been
buying her cocaine and now you're going
to stop buying her cocaine right if she
were ill you would buy her medicine I
wouldn't stop you from doing that this
is not illness this is misbehavior and
you've been financing it yes sir
and that's not to pick on you but to
help you reframe it because when they
start all their routine and they're
going to start it aren't they yes when
you say the emperor has no clothes
they're going to argue and say oh no
he's fully clothed aren't they it's
going to be quite a conversation yes it
is my hand is wedding just thinking
about that's what I mean that's what I
want to give you courage for not to pick
on you but you it's the right thing to
do for them for your relationship with
them and for your family in particular
your husband and you have been talking
about that part right and so that that's
that's where we want you to go hold on
the line and Kelly will pick up and
we'll get you a copy of boundaries by
dr. Henry cloud
you